طيب هذا يقودنا الى السؤال الذي ذكرته قبل
قليل وهو موقف الجزائر من موضوع الحاق غزه
بسلطه رام الله ومرحله ما بعد الحرب والله
انا سمعت البارح كلام يعني يشجع ويشجع
كثير والكثير اللي ردوا وفي لقائي
مع دوله الوزير الاول الفلسطيني كان لي
لقاء احمد شطير كان لي لقاء مطول معه نحنا
لا نرضى ابدا ان تدخل السلطه الفلسطينيه
غزه فوق دبابه اسرا
هذا هو الكلام يعني ف بالتالي من يحلم
بهذه بهذا الحل هو غير داري ب او غير ملم
بالواقع الفلسطيني
وهذا يرجعنا
ل اساس من اسوس الحل يعني هذا كنا هذا
الكلام انا عشته منذ 30 سنه وحتى 40 سنه
كنا نتكلم على استقلاليه القرار الفلسطيني
انا صاحب القرار فيما يخ
فلسطين هم
الفلسطينيون 40 سنه اصبحنا نتكلم اليوم
نفس الكلام لان الكثير نصبوا انفسهم لسان
حال المقاومه او لسان حال الشعب
الفلسطين